alors ils m'ont dit non c'est non
s'asseoir sur un canapé pour être
regardé par des gens assis dans un
canapé c'est la plus grande mise en
abyme de la télévision en finale c'est
une trouvaille de stéphanie ait jamais
brader ses failles et la scénographe et
qui fait tous les décors quand il faut
le rappeler quand même je le dis sur
scène j'ai je suis allée à reculons dans
cette tranche là car le succès des
génies pages de remplacer pas parce
qu'il était irremplaçable succéder à
jacques martin s'est passé si vite il y
avait deux en mairie école des fans mais
me suis dit mais je suis jamais je vais
assurer j'ai beaucoup souffert pendant
un an tout le monde l'a oublié et j'ai
demandé à ma fille qu'elle décore une
table avec des chroniqueurs autour il a
beaucoup et m'a dit mais pourquoi pas un
canapé à 14h on prend le café tous les
français en un canapé plus ou moins
grand je savais pas que ce canapé aurait
une telle important à ouidah pérou c'est
ça fait partie de l'émission mais
vraiment c'est devenu un symbole oui oui
tout à fait alors ce canapé rouge est
tellement confortable qui vous arrive
michel de vous endormir pendant une
interview faisait tellement de métier
que vos lèvres continuer à bouger et ça
a c'est quand même fait quand même
drucker est arrivé à mes invités jean
ley et sur les documents sont à dire de
logan un panneau galles crocodile dundee
drame il s'endormit mais les premières
questions et il s'est endormi
profondément alors quel succès alors
chez ikea on peut acheter le canapé
michel drucker sauf que le problème
c'est qu'il ya adamo qui est coincée
dedans
[Musique]
ouellette efforts en vue
formidable combien de formidables michel
drucker on sait plus quinze mille
formidable 20000 formidable il en est
ainsi à 2 millions de techniciens vous
avez un truc que vous avez appris un
petit peu c'est la bienveillance ah mais
moi je ne connaissais pas c'est un mot
que j'ignorais après avoir allumé tout
le parc pendant vingt ans thierry mettez
un jour mais finalement tu as raison il
n'y a pas de honte à être bienveillant
ouais bah là exactement c'est la vérité
alors
un jour j'ai dit les invités préféré et
se faire sucer drucker quand merdé cher
10 ans et michel a répondu sur un génial
thierry ça fait dix ans qu'ils attendent
venir se faire sucer sur mon canapé et
je m'en foutais en fait en vérité je
m'en foutais jusqu'au jour où vous avez
invité ma fille je me dis quand même il
m'invite pas il invite baffie bon je
rêve n'ont rien contre moi dans ce soir
et c'est vrai que si c'est ça c'est pas
taire par ordre de notoriété pour toi
voilà votre démarche alors j'ai gueulé
jamais j'avais pris batterie pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que j'ai une plus
que de la tendresse pour lui et aussi
parce que j'ai des rapports particuliers
avec sa mère a été obligé de faire
sauter le gosse
vie privée parce qu'elle avait envie de
construire et lui voulaient juste baiser
la petite anecdote
alors un jour on se rencontre dans les
cliniciens aux grosses têtes et jeudi à
michel enfin quand même tu m'a jamais
invité pas invité ben fuite a invité
tout le monde et moi jamais et il m'a
dit je t'invite mais avec ta femme tu
accordes tu m'invites à cause de ma
femme tu me non non mais j'ai une petite
faiblesse pour pour leur aide pour ta
femme alors sérieusement je pense que
tout le monde ma vie thierry tu te druck
les reese et c'est vrai que je me suis
un peu drucké risée mais c'est la série
à c'est moi ce mode rue crise et parce
qu'on dit jamais je me jean pierre
foucault il est michel c'est un peu
hardie sonné un petit peu un petit peu
devenue bank et chaque année c'est un
peu plus si je venais gothique dans fais
gaffe michel parce qu'on commence par du
stand-up ont fini par se coucher tard on
prend plus ses petites pilules et on
n'insulte celle à ce rythme la semaine
prochaine fait un tatouage la semaine
d'après vous pisser sur le canapé n'en
faut faire gaffe quand même voilà vous
tourner mal michel mais je suis au bord
du piercing vous avez écrit sur les murs
de france 2 jean kull delphine ernotte
j'ai écrit ça oui on t'avait michel
ces clans j'avais marqué sur les murs
d'europe 1 je recule lagardère c'est 20
de lagardère fait les gars ils tombent
directement viré parce qu'il se fait
dire je pensais
qu'ils téléphoné
à mon ancien patron qui devait être
patrick de carolis il appelait le bureau
de patrick de carolis respect et disait
il et la grand combe la féline on est en
train de déjeuner dans l'extraordinaire
laurent d'asie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater le leader des tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu